lots of honey's but before all of this
let me introduce and let me invite here
on the stage the general director for
communication in the Commission European
Commission mrs. P R Harding Hilda Hansen
[Applause]
so it's team dignitaries and guests and
dear young Europeans I'm very proud to
welcome you to this very special young
citizens dialogue with president
johannes of romania and the president of
the european commission jean-claude
juncker on this at this historic moment
when president Juncker launched the
debate on the future of Europe and of
our European Union he asked us to
organize many more dialogues between
commissioners and the citizens of Europe
to get this debate going and indeed to
give it traction all over Europe 1,600
dialogues have taken place over the last
almost five years and that is in
addition to a lot of consultations
online and you have today been
discussing and putting a lot of ideas on
the table on what kind of European Union
you want tomorrow president johannes and
my president the president of the
european commission jean-claude juncker
will take part in the EU leaders meeting
where they will talk about the future of
Europe so this is your chance this is
your chance to engage with the two
presidents on the messages that they
should be taking to the meeting with the
other European leaders tomorrow so
please welcome president johannes of
romania
and president Juncker from the European
Commission
[Applause]
your Excellencies you need to give the
sense I saw yesterday when the press
conference of President Juncker in
Brussels it was written behind the walls
it was the the slogan of the unification
in Romania and it's good also for Europe
so we feast shortly introductory remarks
let me introduce his Excellency Romanian
president Klaus
Johannes to have the opening
intervention for this citizens dialogue
that we're having today here in Syria
your excellency you have the floor
buona sera good evening what's my span
true thank you for this beautiful
welcome and I hope you have questions we
will continue in other languages to
Tamil a president a president younger
Comus commissioned artisan Commissioner
not Rajesh
ladies and gentlemen I'm happy to be
here with you to be here with a great
number of young European citizens I'm
honored to be here at this citizens
dialogue on the topic of relevant themes
for the future of Europe especially as
we are here in Cebu a city that these
days mobilizes the attention of the
whole of Europe and which will reunite
European leaders during tomorrow's
summit your presence here is proof
of the closeness we are trying to
consolidate strengthen between political
decision-makers and citizens of course
also of a part need for permanent
dialogue open dialogue and topics that
directly affect the lives of our
citizens it is important for us to
communicate better to double the
progresses we have obtained by applying
European policies through on the
constant information communication about
the benefits brought by the EU to its
citizens added stability balance and
prosperity these are things that we can
often take for granted but they only
come to us because we have the will and
the necessary tools to act together the
summit hosted by Romania tomorrow in Sim
you will have to offer a clear clear
vision for a United future of the
European Union as well as ambitious
goals for the new strategic agenda for
2019 2020 for which will be adopted by
the EU Council in June it's essential
that on this occasion we confirm that
our vision is a common vision
and that beyond any differences and
specificity specificities that are
normal for each member state we are
brought together by our will to work
together and to take the EU project
further as well as to find common
solutions for the complex challenges of
the current world ladies and gentlemen
in just a few weeks
EU elections as well as the beginning of
a new institutional European cycle will
majorly impact the way in which European
policies will evolve in the future years
the efforts to remobilize the trust and
the support of our citizens in the favor
of the European project dialogue at EU
institution level between leaders and EU
citizens are more necessary than ever so
that we are able to meet to react to the
challenges generated by euro skeptical
skeptical or extremist challenges as
well as to ensure the necessary support
for European policies ladies and
gentlemen I strongly believe that the
summit in CBO will remain a remarkable
moment in the history of the European
project a symbolic moment of unity of
commitment for Europe I'm sure that
today's debate
we'll have an optimist note on our
common future inside the European Union
for now I would like to thank you and to
tell you that I am open to your
questions Thank You mr. president
[Music]
you promised to build the bridges in
Europe when you took the presidential
place in the Commission now you have the
floor
I have the floor and I will keep it mr.
president my dear clouds mayor
commissioner
it's my pleasure to be here when I'm in
Romania I'm hesitating between French
because Romania is a member of the fog
Bhavani Luxembourgish because in how
much tablets they do understand
Luxembourgish luxembourgish is not the
most well known language worldwide but
it's the most beautiful and who was
speaking like somebody's there yeah hi
between German French English and this
is indicating how which this country its
culture and how which this nation is and
so I'm happy to attend this citizen
dialog it's the second citizen dialogue
I am attending in Romania the first one
was in Bucharest the important one is
here and I came here not to talk to
lecture to tell you to means watch I
came here to listen so this is not in
line with my natural temperament I want
to listen so thank you for coming thank
you mr. president
Europe is facing many challenges but
also opportunities part of the solutions
are here in the room we have 300 young
people who are already working a lot
today they discussed about the future of
Europe we try to figure out some
solutions for our common future and now
I will give them the floor and the
microphones one by one of course in the
limit of the time please ask shortly
your question and mention towards who
for the gender balance we will start if
a lady
if you agree miss dear president over
here do we have a microphone do we have
microphones okay thank you thank you
very much for your speech my name is
ELISA I'm from Germany and we discussed
today the whole day about solidarity and
social rights but actually we didn't
talk once about migration and also I
read your report mr. Uecker and you
mentioned migration only in two tiny
sections so my question to both of you
would actually be like do you really
think you've solved the question during
these last five years and what will you
like tell tomorrow and also what will
you tell like your successor as a
commission president to do it okay thank
you
I don't like the idea that you have
mentioning my successor I don't know who
that will be but I don't like the idea
to leave the presidency of the
commission but that was my decision two
years ago and so I will stop my job on
the 1st of November - this year in fact
at midnight the 31st of October the
British are supposed to leave at the
31st of October they told the resume I
will leave at midnight so please speed
up the process your question was about
migration when I was taking office in
November 2014 and when I was presenting
myself at the European Parliament one of
the priorities I mentioned as I did you
the election campaign back in spring
2014 was migration and my main request
was let's deal with the migration
problem with solidarity amongst
ourselves it took time to convince
countries to do so but in September
October 2015 the culture ministers took
a decision relocation resettlement and
all this it has worked because all those
who are eligible for relocation have
been located and terms of thousands of
refugees have been resettled so by a
position to the general impression is
the fact that we did what we promised
but the point is that we could not live
alone Italy and Greece and others but
mainly Italy and Greece so we supported
the two countries financially and as far
as human resources are concerned have we
solved the problem now the
because this will be a problem of the
next decades what we have done was to
bring down the number of illegal
refugees in 2015 we had over 1 million
people very often unhappy people the
security people we had 1 million over 1
billion in 2015 the numbers went down by
90% by 80% in a Mediterranean the to
Mediterranean woods the numbers went
down dramatically but we have to to have
a close eye on this and I'm what I'm
advocating is that we as Europeans we
don't have the right to reject in
principle those coming from far these
are not toys they are very often
persecuted and we have to help Europe
has to be the country to place where
those who are persecuted for political
religion religious or philosophical
reasons where they have their place I
will always fight for a European Union
opening the doors not to everyone but
for those who need open doors and were a
lot of people needing open doors thank
[Applause]
migration is one of the more difficult
issues for the European Union and for
the European citizens and I think it's
time for us to be honest about this
sometimes when I watch the news on TV or
discussions I think a lot of people get
the impression that migration has been
invented back in 2015 well guess what
migration is as old as mankind
migrations defined our entire history
migrations changed country's destinies
cultures religions but it's true in 2015
we had a huge wave of migrants this wave
has been triggered by the war in Syria
and practice we the European countries
have not been prepared for that wave we
have not been prepared for that wave
although we should have known better
well maybe now we do as jean claude said
we managed to bring down the number of
we call those irregular migrants down by
90% but of course there are still a lot
of regular migrants were left and if I
could suggest something because that was
your question to the next Commission or
the next institutions is to be well
prepared for migration migration is not
going to stop it's going to stay with us
for a very very long time
so we better prepare and we better come
up with fair clear good regulations good
for Europeans good for the European
countries but fair for the migrants it
is unfair to leave the migrants in the
hands of some people who just want to
make money out of them and then put them
in a country where they are simply lost
that's not how we in Europe should deal
with migration and with migrants in the
European Council we talked quite a lot
about how to tackle migration I became a
president in December 2014 and ever
since I attended I don't know Jean
Claude maybe thirty council meetings or
more out of which maybe on 29 occasions
we talked about migration that's quite a
lot quite a lot of talking for for what
we we finally managed to do however
migration is now sort of under control
but if we want to do better we have to
find better clearer and fairer
regulations and this is exactly what
Romina
stood up for during the current
presidency of the Council of the
European Union which is the Romanian
presidency we have not solved yet the
problem but a certain progress is
obvious and I'm pretty confident that
over the next period we will manage to
come up with such good regulations thank
you thank you so much
let's have a question which the
gentleman in the middle near the camera
please
okay no no in the front sorry please I
was clearly enough near the camera yeah
please don't appreciate intent rebar
arise mr. president my question is for
you today we have discussed several
important matters going from climate
change all the way to the vote for the
European Parliament what is your opinion
about voting as early as 16 I know just
one country in the European Union who
has this that is Austria thank you Thank
You mr. president
your son perfect accord so in chapel
water I agree I totally agree for young
people to be allowed to vote at a
younger age 16 seems okay
but in this case I believe we should
also start learning about democracy a
bit earlier before the first vote
because we don't want to and ourselves
in a situation like now when you go to
vote at 18 and you start learning things
about elections when you are 38 takes
about two in principio soon so yes as a
principal I am for giving the young
generation the possibility to vote but
at the same time I believe that we are
obliged to find a simple clear way to
explain to European citizens
what vote what a vote is about because
if we are to listen just to the
politicians who are in our electoral
campaign we
think that voting is about everything
except for the thing that interests us
in reality voting is about things that
concern us voting is about the future of
the European Union about the safety of
its citizens about the safety of its
borders about a fair but firm control of
migration about climate about the things
that we do with our land all these
things are reflected in our vote for the
European Parliament we can have over
there groups that are responsible and
come up with a plan for a future or just
people who come to the European
Parliament and say that we don't
actually need the European Union which
is certainly counterproductive that's
why it is mandatory to be informed and
yes let's give the young people the
rights to vote
Thank You president merger speed you
more Cote PASOK set enough air that what
the voters hasn't in a concern opinion
yes the ferpa desperate it's a matter of
it's a matter of deciding on how to vote
the European Commission doesn't have the
right to interfere in this decision at
the level of the Member States therefore
my response is that we don't have a
competence in this and but actually I do
because I come from a very specific
place in Luxembourg and at 16 we
proposed to the local authorities to
introduce the optional vote as of as
early as 16 and my citizens voted
but since the vote was optional it
didn't matter for the final decision
however our vote went exactly in the
same direction as that of the people
with the full right to vote when I was
16 therefore I was able to vote the
party whose president I became 20 years
later and I would do the same thing
today I didn't learn anything so here I
was voting when I was 60 venusaur simcha
Kennedy Thank You president it's good to
know that young people want to vote as
soon as possible because this gives us
hope for the democracy for European
citizens and for the European
institutions please good evening this
farce and Fred from friends I my
question is about European transparency
a democracy in fact we have a platform
represents every lobby and the prizes
are putting every year in your lobbying
but it's not obligatory and there's no
examination or sanction about it and for
example plastic Europe depends 1.5
million in 2017 and in 2018
10,000 million which is very weird
sorry your question is and they just
forgot a few millions my question is
right now are you going to put out the
courage to put it obligatory
and then not to let the pressure lobby
upon with a sari there in destroyed and
finishing on this thank you thank you so
much
we Chippewa we are very unfair indeed
myself in commissions president in Sofia
people are assassinated
it means L it's a transparent on topics
regarding transparency
if you can't understand me I will speak
Luxembourgish regarding transparency and
lobby which plays quite an important
role I'm not against lobbying but we
need a way but we need to find a way to
express our opinions because lobbies
lobbying groups as well as lobbying
groups are made up of a lot of people
sometimes unions are lobbying groups and
so on we have oke we had somebody at the
level of the Commission who wanted the
lobby agents to me and get inside to be
recorded in a register we had a thousand
now there are more than this but nobody
in our offices have the right to receive
representatives of certain interest
interests unless they are in school
enrolled in this list of lobbyists we
didn't reduce this list because I think
this is a huge benefit the moment you
want to tell people that a meeting will
be made public suddenly oh the number of
people who want to see you drops
dramatically so whenever you want to
talk to somebody you have to make this
known so we have total transparency at
least at the level of the Commission we
would have wanted the same transparency
rules to be applied to the council of
ministers and the European Parliament
unfortunately we are the only ones
who are transparent but this must change
and I think that I have to say this and
I can say this I can say that when a
member of the European Parliament
receives a visit they have to make this
public the citizens have the right to
know who speaks to whom and about what
thank you okay it's not okay do we have
also a functional oh yeah yeah my
question goes to President Juncker you
were already a minister when most of us
were not born 25 years ago or something
my question is very straightforward do
you think that you're leaving us a
better world than when you entered in
your position as a minister and Prime
Minister and so on I'm especially
thinking on the environment debt that is
left for us and also the financial
depths that is for us to pay thank you
I was appointed a minister my country at
the age of 27 and I served my country
until the age of 60 59 and then I was
elected president the Commission if I
remember correctly the situation in
which I grew up I have to say the world
has become another place to live mainly
the European part of the world we are
the smallest continent although we do
think that we are the masters of the
world which is nonsense
people are richer today than they were
in 54 that's when I was born in December
the 9th of December 54 for those who
want to congratulate me next December no
no things have improved my father was a
steel worker and before becoming a steel
worker he was a soldier a Luxembourg
incorporated by force in the German army
together with three of his brothers was
my life better than yes yes it was
because European Union has as a major
goal to make sure that there will be no
war anymore in Europe we had enough was
so things did improve what is new is the
question duality related to environment
environment was in a better situation in
the fifties sixties and seventies of the
last century we have to focus on climate
change as a commission we did it the
Commission and the European Union
European Union and the Commission we
were the driving forces when it when we
had to decide on the climate change in
Paris
December 2005 but we have to improve our
efforts climate change is the major
problem of the future we are facing two
main problematic domains climate and our
relations with Africa they are
interrelated to some extent but not
always Europe has to be the place where
climate change in the best way possible
thank you so much mr. president
indeed the European Union is providing
peace and prosperity we have a living
proof here in Sibiu where at the time
maryani's managed to do a lot of thing
good things in in an European context so
Europe its delivering prosperity and
peace of course we'd like to get
something for now then we we take the
next question thank you please please be
short my name is Alex and I'm working
with Georgia Konya which is the European
network of churches and Christian
organization advocating social justice
in our workshop on democracy we raised
the question on how can we ensure that
new digital technologies can really be
used to protect our democratic values I
think that the Commission has already
done a lot especially since last month
they released the final ethical guidance
on transfers the artificial intelligence
but how can we how it go on in the
future
shall we create a complete new European
law or continue with the guidance thank
you thank you who'd like to start
it's for the present it's above my
powers mr. president you have to to
answer I think this is this is something
we we should really consider as a huge
challenge because the shift already
happened we'll live in a digital world
it's not something we have to prepare
because it's coming in the future it
happens and guess what
we are not prepared maybe you have been
talking among yourselves about something
which is really coming it's it's called
5g the next generation of communication
guess what it is coming and it is in
itself a form of artificial intelligence
your phone will talk to your car to your
walk to your washing machine to your to
your climate installation back home and
if you're lucky you will understand it
if not well bad luck so my suggestion is
do something to understand it
because this is happening I left my
phone in the back we have been talking
about about phones about smart phones
just a couple of years ago and we
thought wow that would be something we
could not really imagine well today
everybody has a smart phone and we
communicate we exchange all kinds of
information which just a decade ago was
complicated to exchange even among
specialists so yes the Commission has
issued a number of documents on this and
we work on it but personally I am not
satisfied with what's happening in the
European ioan they have to be very very
honest about this
one of the major achievements in the
European Union is the single market we
managed to have a single market for
production for industrial production for
goods we are buying stuff in Romania
which comes from sometimes even from
Luxembourg ahead services come from
Luxembourg and we are selling Romanian
products all over the Union and so on
and so forth
but why don't you try to take your phone
to the foreign country which most of you
did if you come to Romania works fine
because we have we have fast networks
but more often than not if you go abroad
already the phone is not functioning
properly if you try to do more
complicated issues then you find out
that even if we have a single market we
are far from a single market if it comes
to digital well how can we evolve and
prepare the Union for the digital area
which is surrounding us already if we do
not have a single digital market among
us and we are only 28 not before long we
will be 27 so I think we still have a
huge lot of work before us and yes the
question comes ok if we will live in
this digital world how can we be sure
that our our core values will be guarded
that how can we make sure that our
rights will be present and will be
guarded I think this is something which
we will have to sort out with the
Commission with the council
with all the member states because it's
happening and I personally prefer to be
prepared for things that happen
thank you would you like that something
please I think no no but the president
was always inspiring said that he is not
happy with everything happening in
European Union I'm not happy with
everything happening in Romania too
that makes two of us
okay we are still having some minutes to
spend together so let's let's give yes
let's give a chance to speak to the
gentleman in the one of the behind rows
yes please yeah but this is the first
time of the bed who will have the
microphone beside me laughter good
afternoon president Yunker president
johannes thank you very much for coming
here and answering our questions we
really appreciate it I was just reading
this leaflet they are giving us about
the European Union and I saw that in the
part about climate change they mentioned
several ways in which the European Union
is fighting this problem but it also
doesn't mention other ways in which the
European Union is not doing it so my
question is how can we claim to be
tackling global warming while at the
same time we keep subsidizing factory
farming Thanks thank you
you have to make the difference between
what is happening on the level of
European Union when it comes to
legislation and what is happening in
National Member States when it comes to
legislation not everything can be
legislated on the European level but I
have the same feeling the one you were
expressing so it's I will not be the one
putting hurdles in the way of the
movement you were describing and by the
way why do we speak in English everyone
understands English but nobody
understands England
so now that we found out the language
that sinks it's talking in English let's
let's move over please the third row
please I count on your patience and now
it's our time hello can you hear me
laughing good Nam hello
materials from the AFC I'm from the
European trade union Stacy and I'm here
with an amazing team of European
apprentices network which is supported
strongly by you by the European
Commission thanks for this and as we are
we are representing here young workers
and our generation which is the most
valuable and the best educated one we
are saying thanks to the newest
technology and thanks to newest points
of research on the other side we are the
generation which is suffering the most
from precarious working conditions and
my question to you is how you as the
European Commission wants to ensure that
young workers are more protected of
precarious work and create also a more
youthful in the labor market thank you
[Applause]
I had two happy period in my life I had
and I will have after having left the
Commission I was a minister of labor for
17 years that was my best time in life
because if you are Minister of Labour
you have to deal with very concrete
daily problems of the workers my father
as I told you was a steelworker my first
social experience
was the meeting my father with his
working colleagues unionists like you
are in our kitchen
I was listening when they were
discussing the length of the coffee
pours things like that important things
when I became president of the
Commission one of my priorities was the
social dimension of the European Union
which is underdeveloped till now I'm
happy that the Commissioner for Social
Affairs my entire zone is attending this
meeting she's sitting in the first read
excellent and we have done a lot of
things not really recognized but
generally we have reformed the postal
workers directive same salary for the
same work on the same place this has
never been done before I'm against
European Union where social dumping is
the booth I'm in favor of European Union
where social tennis is the word we were
establishing a so-called cockerel pillar
yes my chief of press is who is Greek
but which is the only one in the
Commission understands the dimwit ish
because the British don't like me to say
is a soccer they want me to say it's a
pillar but it's a sock mr. chief
spokesperson
we did it in good luck we really have
adopted decisions directives on the
conciliation between family life and
working life so we have done a lot of
things fight against cancer all these
things have been done but it's not
enough we are not even in the middle of
the way we are starting to take the
right Avenue I'm strongly in favor of
further developing the social dimension
of the European Union and I would like
to invite the workers employees to go on
the 26th of May to the voting boxes if
workers are not taking part in this
marvelous project called European Union
nobody will vote for them they have to
vote for themselves and I would like to
launch a trade ye to everything to
everyone to vote for the European
elections and everyone has to know this
very day I am Europe and everyone has to
ask him service all the others would
vote like me
what kind of European Union would we
have if everyone would vote in favor of
the extremest what would be the European
reality of tomorrow so just just a few
words on on this because it is important
I know my my friend jean-claude is not
going to be happy because again I have
to say something which we did not do yet
in the European Union
if we read the statistics in most
European countries the youth
unemployment is considerably higher than
the general unemployment well guess what
somewhere people make a mistake because
young people are eager to work
eager to make money eager to be part of
the society so if they are not means
that the system has a flaw and this has
to be corrected
well obviously the problem is in the
educational system because if we
prepared the young generation for the
jobs that actually are on the market
they would get those jobs but many of
our educational systems prepare the
young generation for jobs that sometimes
don't even exist anymore when they
finish school and this this is too bad
so we have to go back to our educational
systems become more way more proactive
we have to link the educational system
to the labor market we have to take care
of the young generation this is not
something we have to do because young
people are nice because all politicians
say well you're the future you're nice
obviously but we have to do that as a
measure of self conservation the young
generation is the future of a society
that's a fact that's not a nicety I say
so we better take care of the young
generation and do whatever whatever is
necessary to make them integrate as soon
as possible
this is absolutely vital for our
societies and it is even more important
for the European Union where in most
countries
the demographic pyramid is not the right
one it should be this one but it's this
one we have we don't have enough young
people to maintain the level of our
society unless we teach them more with
each them better and we integrate them
as soon as they finish school this
obviously has to do not only with the
education it has to do with fair
treatment with good conditions at work
with a number of measures which
politicians should take to make the
immersion easier so all this is
something we still have to work on my
opinion after having listened to the
president that understand why he didn't
reduce his mark by saying that I would
be unhappy with what he was intending to
say I'm very happy with what you said
because this gives me the opportunity to
remind you that during our mandate as a
commission 12.6 millions of jobs have
been created this gives me the
opportunity to tell you that the
unemployment was never as low as it is
since the year 2000 this gives me the
opportunity to tell you that you've
unemployment went down from 21 to 14
percent which is obviously too high but
things have have been improved yes the
fact that our societies are becoming
older is a problem because already now
having an average age of 44 points will
yes you are the oldest part of the
planet and this is
effect which we have to regret but
European Union Commission cannot act
when it comes to these points it's the
member states who have to put into place
policies allowing people to to grow as
populations the Commission is not in
charge of the coordinate le below thank
you for visiting us
probably not the closing remarks because
I learned that we have still time for
the closing remarks we hit still still
have three four minutes maybe if you
yeah okay then you should decide
yourself I have to choose between you
and you him okay thank you for your
patience so in your opinion when you
have patience and you fight till the end
you you get the mic at least please
thank you very much my name is Marius
I'm European and I want to use the
opportunity to say goodbye to you mr.
young and when you say goodbye I think
you also should say thank you I want to
and I'm not always agreeing of agreed
with what you did politically but I want
to thank you for being a a true European
defending European democracy European
values and the rule of law against we
have to call them fascists coming up so
thank you for that
my question is we are here because
tomorrow it's the CBO summit on the
future of Europe and you miss the
president you just said young people are
the future
so if tomorrow you decide on the future
of Europe and we are the future of
Europe and you decide on us why aren't
we invited to the sea because I remember
in Guttenberg we were there people read
the social summit in Gothenburg where we
made the tackle or how you called it so
it the social pillar yeah it would be
possible so that would be great
maybe if you could explain thank you
very much thank you so much it would be
the last question and maybe you could
combine the thousand demise it's
difficult to invite all of you because
there are already too many members
attending this summit no no no 28 member
states two more 27 because the British
will not be there it's promising I've
met the social partners the day before
yesterday in order to prepare this
severe summit and I'm very of meeting
young many not women
lobbyists without indicating to the
press that I was meeting them because
these are not dangerous meetings because
we are discussing together Martha's
house how the future will be organized I
have proposed in September 2017 to have
a European Council in CBO because I
wanted to show that European Union
that's not only bursts everyone is busts
I'm not alone in Brussels would I be
alone in Brussels things would be better
but I'm not
I'm not the illudium buses all the
governments are part of the so-called
buzzin system all the members of
national and European Parliament's are
part of Brussels but I wanted to show to
the rest of the Europeans that it's not
only Brussels it's not only Booker as
Paris Berlin the European reality is
taking place here in the cities in the
towns in the villages and the real
reason was that they have never been in
Sibiu and I always wanted when I was a
Prime Minister to visit the CPU because
you have to know this it's German
propaganda saying that this region and
Sibiu have been discovered by sections
no no it was it was Luxembourgers boy
Moyes
you know what I like best in these
debates with young people they are so
provocative and they give us the
possibility to come up with real answers
so let me let me tell you one
I hope it's real for you mario's I'm
European - jean-claude this European -
and if you were not Europeans you are
not you won't be sitting here you would
be going somewhere else more it more
interesting events thank you for being
here and staying here with us
you know what these issues will be in
the summit this exactly this is why
jean-claude and myself came to talk to
you this is what politicians do if they
if they really want to have a feedback
if not you can write the communique and
that's it
so junk Laden myself we do not only need
this feedback we want this feedback so
through us you will be there so you have
two voices in the summit of CBO but you
should have and I think you will you
have more voices because there's the
phenomenon we call democracy democracy
goes like this everybody goes and votes
for the leaders the leaders go and do
their best and decide for the society
well this is what we do in the council
in the European Council we the leaders
meet to discuss about the Union we don't
discuss about our own private issues we
don't we do not go there believe it or
not to discuss issues of the parties we
come from we really talk about the Union
and about problems of the Union but of
course
we do not go there by our own will we go
there because we have been elected so if
you want to have good leaders in the
council go and vote thank you so much
president - hani's president Juncker and
now let me invite you for a big family
group photo here downstairs if you it
would be complicated so it was the the
idea to have together or the proof of
this dialogue to get into tomorrow in
the council meeting together if this
photo we should yeah please
the pledge of segunda nada
okay please everybody remain seated just
to give the opportunity to the two
presidents to take their places she bu
started as an European cultural capital
now it's a gastronomic capital so I hope
you will enjoy this but in the meantime
let's have the
thank you so much
[Applause]
you
[Music]